und jetzt ab in den dschungel fraglich
ist ob tatsächlich alle einreisen dürfen
denn ab dem 21 januar warten zehn
deutsche promis im dschungelcamp auf die
wettkämpfe auf die prüfungen im
südafrikanischen bull startet in elf
tagen das berühmte berüchtigte
dschungelcamp die promis müssen aber
natürlich erst mal dorthin kommen und
tatsächlich sind die ersten in diesen
minuten angekommen wir waren dabei an
bord und haben vor dem abflug in
frankfurt mal ein paar stimmen
eingeschaltet die haben uns mal an
eingefangen die haben uns mal an bevor
wir nach südafrika schalten
mein vater war ja der erste
dschungelkönig ich habe ihn damals
begleitet nach australien
das ist für mich natürlich jetzt mit
mega emotionen verbunden weil ich weiß
er ist diesen weg schon gegangen jetzt
liegt es an mir diesen weg zu gehen und
ich weiß ja wieder zu schauen und das
ist natürlich total emotional natürlich
habe ich auch ängste aber ich glaube ich
gehe also ich bin da schon relativ mutig
was ich natürlich schrecklich finde und
ich glaube das geht jedem so ist so
diese ganzen essens prüfung diese ganz
fürchterlichen dinge dann zu essen ich
glaube das wird für jeden schlimmsten
sein ich habe einen großen wunsch und es
ist junge könig zu werden das ist ja
klar das kann man nicht richtig planen
aber ich werde mein bestes geben und das
werde ich auf jeden fall schaffen also
lukas ist mental und ihr absolut ja sehr
willensstark erzielt durch was er sich
vornimmt er ist körperlich fit was soll
passieren da kann nur gewinnen ich
glaube das war jetzt einer der nächte wo
ich wirklich sehr unruhig fast gar nicht
geschlafen habe und natürlich ist es ein
abenteuer lange drauf gewartet natürlich
wissen ziel ins dschungelcamp zu gehen
wenn man die schiene mit reality tv
pferd und ich freue mich einfach drauf
da ich ja auch eine große spinnenphobie
habe glaube ich sind es nicht nur das
wird schon die prüfung seien im freien
zu schlafen nicht irgendwie überdacht zu
sein und da laufen ja auch die
krabbeltiere und spinnen und war also
das wird schon die prüfung seien
überhaupt ein auge im camp zu machen und
natürlich die prüfungen mein großes ziel
ist dschungelkönigin 2022 wäre natürlich
unsere reporterin kira ortmann war für
uns ganz nah dran die nämlich den
dschungel flieger mit nach südafrika
geflogen kira was sind deine eindrücke
von der reise wäre es mit dir im flieger
gewesen ja wir sind hier jetzt gerade am
flughafen in johannesburg müssen gleich
tatsächlich noch einen weiteren liga
nimmt damit wir dann auch wirklich in
den dschungel kommt direkt am kruger
national park ist für mich das
dschungelcamp in diesem jahr aufgebaut
und wir waren jetzt gerade im flieger
von zürich eben nach johannesburg unter
anderem mit filip tapalovic das ist
einer der teilnehmer der letztes jahr
schon in der dschungelshow mitgemacht
hat und der daneben sein ticket dabei
gewonnen hat um jetzt irgendwann diesem
jahr teilzunehmen und er hat ganz spiel
schon während des fluges gepostet man
sieht ihnen eigentlich die ganze zeit
nur wenn er im flieger sitzt dann geht
man jetzt gerade sieht mit seinem handy
am ohr es machen oder am essen oder am
schlafen für die teilnehmer ist nämlich
tatsächlich was ganz besonderes sie
fliegen alle business class und die
meisten sind das um ehrlich zu sein
nicht so gewohnt das hat philipp zum
beispiel jetzt auch selber schon
zugegeben dass er gesagt hat das bin ich
noch nie voll geflogen das ist also noch
luxus tue hier die anreise war gab es
während des fluges ein paar turbulenzen
die waren aber nicht der rede wert ja
und dann geht es heute abend
wahrscheinlich dann schon direkt ins
blut weil sie erst mal in die quarantäne
und dann ja bald auch in den dschungel
wir werden am zuversichtlichsten am
board dschungelkönig zu werden
tatsächlich sind ja die meisten
kandidaten immer von sich selber sehr
überzeugt die meisten kandidaten sind ja
auch selbst schon realität die wir stars
und wollen sich da eben profilieren
wollen sich da auf eigen und d stehen
hier sehr sehr selbstbewusst unter
anderem auf belebte er noch gesagt hat
ja ich nehme das ding nach hause aber
tatsächlich wie man jetzt so aus den
eigenen reihen beziehungsweise auf von
hinter den kulissen gehört haben alle
ganz schön angst vor lukas portal ist
den wir vorher auch im interview hier
gezeigt haben weil der hat natürlich
erfahrung durch seinen vater der ja auch
schon dschungelkönig geworden ist und er
einfach eine große sympathie hat auch
mit dem hintergrund dass daniela
katzenberger er seine frau ist deswegen
vor dem haben glaube ich die meisten
angst haben ja viele kandidaten auch vor
den mahlzeiten im dschungel du hast das
erste flugzeug schon angesprochen was
gab es da für die kandidaten worauf
durften die sich noch mal so richtig
freuen worüber also im flugzeug da war
von maden und sowas noch eine spur da
gab es wirklich noch sehr sehr gut das
essen wie gesagt die teilnehmer sind
auch business class geflogen da konnten
sie sich dann ja sogar aussuchen was
isst zum frühstück gab was ist beim
abendessen gab wir haben gestern abend
gab es ein hähnchen curry unter anderem
ein kino am salat also sehr gesund auch
und das werden sie jetzt die nächsten
tage zwar auch noch genießen können wenn
sie jetzt in ihrem ich glaube dass es
ein 5 sterne hotel direkt am
nationalpark der und danach eben nicht
mehr danach gibt einer weisung boden ich
wollte ich gerade fragen wie sehen denn
die nächsten elf tagen noch aus bevor es
losgeht die teilnehmer gehen jetzt
erstmal alle in quarantäne denn sie sind
natürlich alle bisher getestet werden
sich auch nach rtl-angaben alle fünf
fragen pcr testen damit es da eben kein
risiko kein risiko gibt bezüglich der
des corona virus einer corona infektion
und deswegen gehen jetzt alle erstmal
ins luxushotel bleiben da noch für 11
tage also bis wirklich zum start und
müssen sich da quasi erst mal ein eagle
wir haben jetzt heute gesehen philipp
ist aber auch mit drei freunden
unterwegs eigentlich ist er eine person
heraus aber da werden wir natürlich auch
noch mal genauer gucken wer hier
wirklich mit wem verreist wie haben sich
es ist aber auf jeden fall schon mal zu
viert ganz nett gemacht und werden jetzt
in ihrem luxus hotel an kuka
nationalpark ja sich wahrscheinlich auch
noch ein paar schöne tage machen
geburtstag ja ein bisschen schwieriger
vielleicht in zehn tagen ist es soweit
kakerlaken ekelprüfungen promis am limit
das dschungelcamp
2022 das geht los und dieses jahr
erstmals in südafrika die ersten
kandidaten sind schon gelandet und bild
ist mit dabei am flughafen in flieger am
gepäckband unsere reporterin kira
ortmann sie verfolgt die prominenz auf
schritt und tritt
so genannte ruhe vor dem sturm
im kleinen propeller flieger geht es für
lukas cordalis harald glööckler christin
opera manuel flickinger und philipp
pawlowitsch in den dschungel nach
südafrika und neben den begleitpersonen
der promis ist natürlich auch bild mit
dabei
ankunft am flughafen in weeze bergen ja
ich war im schweiß lang unterwegs aber
ich bin eigentlich fit ich fühle mich ja
man keine zwischendrin immer zu wissen
der law schlafen und jetzt die
temperatur das ist so richtig sommer da
kann man sich wohl fühlt hat lukas denn
eigentlich das geschenk von seiner frau
daniela katzenberger mit dabei da meine
frau wollte mir tatsächlich im bh in
meinen koffer schmuggeln den habe ich
aber zu hause gelassen ich habe zu hause
gelassen weil ich mir nicht vorstellen
konnte den irgendwie gebrauchen zu
können denn als augenklappe ist er zu
groß eventuell als fallschirm aber dann
und dann geht es los zuerst mit den
altbekannten dschungel jeeps in jeweils
eigene kleine luxus bungalows mitten in
der safari bevor es dann ins
dschungelcamp
2022 geht
so und das war noch lange nicht alles
denn jetzt gibt es sogar noch mehr
brandheiße dschungel hughes bisher waren
ja zehn kandidaten der neuen staffel von
ich bin ein star holt mich hier raus
bekannt und wir haben erfahren es wird
noch eine weitere
überraschungskandidaten im hauptcast
geben und hier können sie schon mal
raten wer das sein könnte welches
tv-sternchen könnte sich hier unter
verbergen wir fragen unsere welt live
show chefin nina kirst
ja na ja also ich sag mal so richtig
eingefleischte träsch fans werden sie
erkennen aber der otto normal zuschauer
würde ich sagen er nicht und ich gebe es
auch zu auch ich musste noch einmal nach
googeln die dame heißt arata vita ist 28
jahre alt und ist in deutschland bekannt
geworden durch ex on the beach das ist
eine kuppel show oder ist man auf einer
in einer warmen gegend und sucht
eigentlich nach der großen liebe und
dann trifft man dort auf seinen ex also
konflikte vorprogrammiert die ist aber
keine unbekannte sie kommt aus
österreich und hat dafür zehn jahren
tatsächlich schon mal in einer show
mitgemacht der saturday night fever da
geht es so um die party jugend von
österreich da ist sie schon mit sehr
derben sprüchen aufgefallen und ist bei
dem publikum so gut angekommen dass sie
tatsächlich noch eine eigenen so ein
spin-off bekommen hat und hatte mehrere
jahre später noch mal probiert und hatte
eine eigene sendung haltet euch fest mit
hirn charme und melone in der sie sich
vor kameras unters messer gelegt hat und
sich unter anderem die brüste vergrößern
lassen also so wie sie jetzt aussieht
sah sie früher nicht aus warum wird
diese sensationelle sensation könnte
jetzt erst bekannt gegeben tatsächlich
war das ein relativ kurzfristige
entscheidung also wir haben gehört dass
man eigentlich mit 10 geplant hat mit
zehn kandidaten sich aber immer offen
gehalten hat ob man gegebenenfalls auch
noch einen elften kandidaten dazu holt
und hat sich jetzt letztendlich dafür
entschieden meiner meinung nach ist das
eine gute wahl denn gerade von diesen
jüngeren kandidatinnen ich guck mal so
ein bisschen zurück sarah knappig gina
lisa lohfink die auch nur bekannt worden
weil sie bei germany's next topmodel
mitgemacht haben und dann rein gegangen
sind ins dschungel die haben da richtig
für stimmung gesorgt und ich glaube dass
die auch für ordentlich biss sein kann
dies wahnsinnig von sich überzeugt
sagt auch schon ja ich bin ja bekannt
dafür dass ich sexy bin macht auch
keinen hehl aus ihren ganzen
schönheitsoperation also die brüste sind
und dass es unecht gesicht ist voll mit
botox und fillern
glücklos noch sie wird auf jeden fall
vielleicht das weibliche pendant zu
harald glööckler so was das
ersatzteillager angeht aber janina josef
jahren ist ja auch noch drin das teppich
dividiert ja auch einiges machen lassen
also ich glaub ich kann dafür besorgen
sie hat auch schon angekündigt
vielleicht findet sie ja dort auch einen
mann den sie gut findet da würde mir
dann philipp der pablo witsch einfallen
weil der war zum beispiel auch bei der
bachelor red der ist sucht auch nach der
großen liebe ist ungefähr ihr alter hat
einen stählernen körper also das können
können passt für unterhaltung ist also
mehr als gesorgt mit der neuen
kandidatin träumst du ihr auch chancen
auf die krone ein
oft haben die menschen gewonnen von
denen ich gar nicht so sehr erwartet man
habe dabei ja zum beispiel william
borucki die es damals ins camp gegangen
mit der hat keiner so ja die ist süß
gewesen aber dass die sich am ende so
durch selbst und diva diva traf die war
lustig aber
den sieg traue ich ihr nicht zu ich
glaube da gibt es andere kandidaten zum
glück ja traurig den sieg zu einem lukas
cordalis auch am ende gewinnen dann
nämlich doch immer die dienen
einigermaßen gutes herz haben obwohl die
nick hatte ich so ein gutes herz apropos
desiree nick sie hat er gestern gesagt
ihr favorit ist eric stehe fest ja lukas
cordalis hat natürlich beste
voraussetzungen sein vater hat schon den
dschungel thron erste er war der erste
wieder erste dunkel könig genau und dann
ja auch seine schwägerin also die
schwester von seiner frau ebenfalls
dschungelkönigin wortes stimmt das liegt
irgendwie das gehen liegt scheinbar in
der familie deswegen hat lukas auf jeden
fall gute chancen vor allen dingen ist
das ein sehr harmonisch
harmoniebedürftiger mensch der ist
keiner der so krass an act oder
schlecht über andere redet und ich
glaube jemand der loyal ist und der so
ein bisschen auch so der herden führer
sein kann derjenige der so aufs
lagerfeuer aufpasst und guckt dass alle
irgendwie miteinander auskommen er hat
schon immer ganz gute chancen also unter
die top 3 wird lukas cordalis auf jeden
fall kommen glückler kann es auch weit
bringen wenn dann nicht zu weinerlich
ist und du hast gesagt top 3 harald
glöckler dann
lukas und nummer 3
wahnsinnig schwierig lass mich überlegen
haha ich weiß nicht ich mache mich mal
ablehnen bliebe mir kämpfen morgen
morgen vielleicht morgen ich überlegt
mir das noch mal ich bin noch nicht ganz
sicher aber die beiden auf jeden fall
eine frau muss noch dabei sein es
beginnen wir noch ein bisschen zeit
und dann könnten wir eine wette hier
machen und
thomas und ich haben eine historie mit
wänden die wetteinsätzen sind immer ganz
komischer weise verliere ich
komischerweise komischerweise stellt
sich hinterher immer raus das ist
absprachen im hintergrund hohe mittelmaß
morgen mache ich meine top 3 und wenn
die so eintritten darf ich mit dir live
im fernsehen eine dschungelprüfung
gerne etwas zu essen ich habe den vip
radar moderierten mehr gibt's nicht
danke daniel tödliche schlangenarten
ekel-prüfung staubige und trockene hitze
er all das kommt in neun tagen dann auf
die neuen dschungelcamper zu nächste
woche freitag am 21 januar startet die
nächste staffel von ich bin ein star
holt mich hier raus zum ersten mal nicht
im australischen dschungel sondern
der linie des krüger nationalparks in
südafrika zebras und giraffen stadt
koalas und kängurus nach und nach
trudeln auch die kandidaten ein und bild
ist natürlich mit dabei unter ihnen auch
noch ein ganz neues gesicht aus bisher
elf bekannte kandidaten sind nämlich nun
zwölf geworden und um wen es sich da
handelt das wollen wir jetzt besprechen
mit unserer bild live show chefin
giannina kirche saanen ist guten morgen
ja das cast ist also jetzt komplett
zwölfter kandidat kommt mit dazu wer es
handelt sich um einen mann der seit 35
jahren im showbusiness ist und wirklich
alle großen namen der branche kennt denn
er hat sie beschützt es ist peter althof
personenschützer bodyguard michael
schumacher pamela anderson claudia
schiffer mohammed ali er hat sie
wirklich alle gehabt wenn man so sagen
möchte und ist mit ihnen durch die welt
gereist und hat sozusagen für ihre
sicherheit gesorgt und dieser mann ist
jetzt im camp dabei und ihn kennt man ja
eigentlich nicht auf solchen sendungen
was hat ihn jetzt dazu gebracht zu sagen
ich möchte jetzt schon die richtig gute
show habe ich gehen heldt natürlich vip
erfahren und es wird natürlich auch
spannend sein ob man die eine oder
andere geschichte am lagerfeuer erzählen
kann allerdings würde ich sagen dass die
riege der prominenz die er betreut hat
ein bisschen größer war als die die da
jetzt wirklich auch im camp ist weil das
sind ja eher mehr sagen wie mattsee bis
z promis ein grund warum er in den
dschungel gehen könnte ist natürlich das
geld also er ist jetzt seit 35 jahren im
geschäft
allerdings ist natürlich auch er durch
corona gebeutelt es gibt keine
veranstaltung mehr
wenig zu tun für diesen bereich für
diesen security-bereich zuletzt hat er
tatsächlich senioren betreut letzten
jahre und hat den seine dienste seine
fahrdienste angeboten ja also das geld
wird da auf jeden fall eine rolle
spielen wie bei allen anderen oder zu 90
prozent der anderen kandidaten eben auch
und wir wollen jetzt mal nach südafrika
schauen in den vergangenen stunden
landete nämlich wieder einige teilnehmer
inklusive peter und wir waren natürlich
ganz nah dran welche längst da ist er
frisch angekommen ist und wir noch
ankommen wird schaue man sagen
tag 3 der ankünfte und südafrika wird
immer wilder zwölf deutsche nun ja
bekanntheit und hübschen sich langsam
ans dschungelcamp 22 grad fünf der
wackeren biaggis lassen sich gerade
bereits vor ort noch den schampus
schmecken kuscheln sich noch mal unter
die hotelbett decken können sich eine
kugel pflanzerei oder genießen die
südafrikanische sonne auf der safari
sowie das da links im bild schön
na gut aber am 21 januar ist schluss mit
saus und braus dann geht's für die
britschen form ist los mit krabbelt camp
knatsch und krokodil kurze gerichten und
sieh mal einer an da trudeln sie ein
weitere walbusch bewohner hier rollt
roland reisegepäck richtung urwald und
für tina beginnt jetzt quasi urlaub
denkt sie erst eindruck super ist es
warm ist schön ich habe spaß hausfrauen
leben halten das wurde jetzt nicht
machen ich habe eingekauft gekocht
geputzt und so weiter welche schulischen
angelegenheiten gekümmert das fällt
jetzt erstmal ist weg hier das ist ja
auch mal ganz schön ja wahrer luxus so
ein trash tv experiment hier ist sie die
garantie für nackte tatsachen bachelor
kandidatin linda nobody ich habe mir für
mich selbst die krone schon zugesichert
und das ist egal was außen rum ist egal
wie es passiert gewonnen habe ich
sowieso ex on the beach gesicht tara
tabitha tauscht diese formation
waldgegend eine prüfung und das genießt
sie jetzt auch noch mal so richtig ich
weiß nicht ob so oft gedacht dass ich
meinen könnte dort habe ich freue mich
dass ich dabei bin der dschungel war
noch nie so sicher bodyguard peter
althof kann mit a promis gut aber
beweist er auch ein sicheres händchen
bei den trash stars oder das gut ist
maxi
zwei leute kennenlernen wenn das gas
geben und vor allem was gut ist einmal
begegnung sehen stimmt sonderbare
positiv ich kenne die hauptveranstaltung
ich mache mir jahrelang schon das boxen
die salahis abbrach und das ist immer
wieder leute in der vip lounge vor der
die wohl dabei sind und es ist bestimmt
lustig aber wie ich kenne die charaktere
in alle netze richtig das muss ich alle
fragen und schauspielerin anouschka
renzi ist übrigens auch schon gelandet
allerdings still und heimlich mit ihrem
lebensgefährten den kurs nochmal schnell
mitnehmen mit zweisamkeit ist nämlich
demnächst schluss im bus ja ja richtig
gezählt ganz komplett ist die
abenteuerlustige truppe nicht da nina
josef jahren genießt lose freiheit
gerade noch über den wolken und für eric
steht fest wird die reise sogar zum
richtigen familienausflug der gns setzt
da erscheint mit sack und pack also
gemeint sind frau edith und den beiden
kids am berliner flughafen während seine
liebsten also die über 30 grad genießen
sitzt eric mit der trash truppe am
lagerfeuer was hat der eigentlich noch
zu erzählen ich glaube jetzt geht es
darum zu zeigen wie eric steht fest
fliegt und was passiert wenn er einfach
auch mal ein bisschen lustig ist
das klingt doch unfassbar lustig
deswegen anschnallen und los geht die
sause
ganz genau los geht die sause und
annelie dabei ist uns unsere reporterin
kira ob man die wir jetzt live in
südafrika sprechen hallo kira kira du
bist die ganze zeit dabei gewesen wie
muss man sich jetzt den ort vorstellen
wo alle ankommen und zusammenkommen
ja wir stehen hier tatsächlich gerade an
diesem ort an dem alle ankommen dass es
der flughafen hier in hersbruck und man
muss sagen es ist jetzt nicht so ein
flughafen wie man den kennt mit einem
ordentlichen check in schalter oder
irgendwie cafés und restaurants in der
nähe nein wir können hier im hintergrund
mal vorsichtig film denn es ist ein ganz
ganz kleines areal hier mit einem
kleinen parkplatz wir können immer
einmal um die ecke drehen das ist
nämlich das gepäckband was ist hier gibt
wo ihm die koffer dann ankommen von den
promis ja es ist alles ein bisschen
anders als man es eben kennt aber eben
weil wir hier ja direkt beim dschungel
sind wir sind sie direkt quasi nebenan
am cougar nationalpark und hier werden
jetzt auch gleich eric steht fest und
seine familie und janina josephine hier
ankommen die richtigen das hat ja gerade
noch gesagt ja er wird mal zeigen wie
lustig er sein kann ich bin gespannt wie
lustig er das wetter hier finden wird
denn heute nacht hat es die ganze zeit
gewiss hat und heute ist es wirklich
sehr regnerisch gestern als die anderen
promis angekommen sind sparen auch
wirklich strahlender sonnenschein und 30
grad jetzt sind es immer noch 25 grad
also sollten uns nicht beschweren aber
wie gesagt heute etwas regnerisch und da
bin ich gespannt ja wie die promis
darauf reagieren wir haben nicht
wirklich im strahlenden sonnenschein
erwartet jetzt regnet zwar kann also
richtig ungemütlich auch werden für die
camp kandidaten du hast ja mit den
meisten schon sprechen können wie ist
denn die stimmung unter den kandidaten
gibt es vielleicht schon den ersten zoff
oder bano
spannung auf jedenfalls hofft noch nicht
da haben sich die kandidaten bisher sehr
zurückgehalten ich muss auch sagen die
kandidaten halten noch meistens sehr
abstand zueinander viele unter anderem
auch tina ruland eher gesagt sie will
auch die kandidaten jetzt im vorfeld
bevor es dann wirklich ins camp geht
doch gar nicht kennenlernen weil sie die
dann da in ruhe kennenlernen möchte und
dann eben unter diesen voraussetzungen
erstmals dann mit denen sprechen möchte
unter anderem haben sich trotzdem schon
ein paar grüppchen gebildet philipp
pawlowitsch der saß zum beispiel im
flieger mit michael kring enger zusammen
der ehemalige lausanner
kandidat der bei tiefen
mitgemacht hat und da gab es schon
kleine gruppierungen zwischen dem
partyvolk das waren philipp otto und
aber auch solchen wie harald glööckler
und lukas cordalis die sich eher
zurückgezogen haben die wirklich ganz
entspannte angereist sind und er noch
mal so richtig in sich gegangen sind
bevor sie jetzt in die quarantäne gehen
das ist mir besteht nämlich jetzt auf
dem zettel sie sind alle in
unterschiedlichen lodges jetzt gerade er
einquartiert und ja dann werden sie erst
in den kommenden tagen wirklich alle
aufeinander treffen und dann kommt es
erst zum ersten kennenlernen kira du
hast es gerade schon gesagt mit party
ist es bald vorbei denn die quarantäne
beginnt sie werden abgeschirmt wie sieht
das aus wie genau muss man sich das
vorstellen was ist das für eine lodge
ist das noch luxus oder ist das schon
eher
jugendherberge und sind sie da wirklich
ganz alleine oder dürfen ihre
begleitpersonen mit in quarantäne
tatsächlich sind sie alle in 5 sterne
luxus lodges untergebracht und diese
leute sie sind wirklich sowas von toll
aus also jeder hat einen eigenen pool
und es gibt richtig noch richtig gutes
afrikanisches essen da ist dann viel
fleisch dabei philipp zum beispiel hat
heute morgen schon auf insgesamt sein
frühstück gepostet da gab es dann
fleisch pommes salat zum frühstück aber
das scheint hier tradition bei uns zum
beispiel gab es ganz viel obst und
gemüse dementsprechend lassen sie es
sich jetzt auf jeden fall noch gut gehen
und sie sind jetzt mit den
begleitpersonen ganz genau richtig er
untergebracht philipp zb ist mit dem
sehr kann ja wo es auch eine reality tv
person untergebracht und hat auch noch
eine weitere begleitperson dabei harald
glööckler und so weiter sie sind alle
mit ihren begleitpersonen jetzt in
diesen rogers untergebracht ist es nicht
ein großes hotel sondern eben solche
kleinen unterkünfte ganz wie man hier in
südafrika hat mitten im dschungel hier
auch mal ein live aus südafrika danke
für die infos kia